[Musique]
pour l'instant on a beaucoup d
interrogations on n'a toujours pas de
consigne dans les services
mes collègues sont sont très sceptiques
on espère avoir des instructions fermes
cette fois ci est d'arrêter le laxisme
notamment les consignes qu'on a vu lors
du dernier confinement avec des
consignes de ne pas aller dans certains
quartiers difficiles
donc on espère que cette fois ci on aura
des consignes beaucoup plus ferme
le souci c'est que on est dans un
créneau horaire c'est là où on a le
moins d'effectifs
on n'a que quatre cents un peu plus de
450 effectifs en brigade de nuit sur le
département ce qui est très peu parce
que si vous enlevez malheureusement les
malades qui seront forcément touché par
aussi le co vie de 10,9
on est sur ce créneau horaire où on a le
moins d'effectifs sur le département et
donc on pense qu'il y aura de nombreux
décalages de fonctionnaires de jour qui
iront renforcer nos collègues de nuit
oui surtout que dans les yvelines il
faut rappeler que lors du dernier
confinement on a eu des périodes de
violences urbaines très violente avec je
vous dis des quartiers ou des collègues
avaient pour instruction de ne pas
intervenir de ne pas aller patrouille et
donc si vous voulez on espère enfin que
le gouvernement donnera des instructions
des moyens mes collègues et que surtout
les tribunaux suivront et émettront des
peines exemplaires aux personnes qui ne
respectent pas le confinement ou qui
s'en prennent à mes collègues durant
cette période